hi there steve kaufman here again to
talk about language learning of course
and today i want to talk about grammar
correction
and in terms of a very interesting
concept and that is the difference
between
performance and learning and i'm going
to leave a link in the description box
to a video by
a person that i follow who puts out very
interesting
videos on youtube about learning whose
name is robert bjork
and his this particular video talks
about
the fact that the performance is
something that we can measure learning
is more difficult to measure
sometimes performance is not a good
indicator
of learning and how does that all relate
back to grammar correction so teachers
like to correct
uh and very often students want to be
corrected and it's often called grammar
correction although in my experience i
think learners of languages more often
make mistakes in terms of their choice
of words
rather than necessarily in terms of
grammar however in general i have found
that grammar correction
doesn't do much uh i know myself that
you know when i'm learning a language
typically i'll have one or two online
sessions a week after i reach a certain
point
and i'll be corrected by my tutor at
link and she usually will give me a list
of all my mistakes and uh i study them
and the next time i meet with her
chances are i make the same mistake
again and i know that because i get the
same phrase or the same word back which
i then study
so that the correction doesn't correct
you
it does signal something that you know
where you have a problem
but
so many things influence your
performance on a given day for example i
know
that if i have a um
you know online discussion with a tutor
in the language that i'm learning
i'm going to perform differently on
different days
if i say meet this person once a week
and in the intervening week i have read
and listened to a lot of the language i
know that i'm learning i'm i'm confident
that i'm learning but my performance in
the following week is sometimes worse
than it was the previous week so many
things influence it my mood the time of
day whether i was tired or not we all
know that in speaking a foreign language
we will perform better with some people
than with other people
depending on the subject of the
discussion there's so many things that
affect our performance another example
is
i often mention you know english
canadian school children who study
french for 10 years
and they're tested so there's this
performance aspect they're tested they
do well on their tests because they they
study for the tests and they study
sort of very isolated things like
conjugation tables or whatever and
they're able to perform on the test but
over the 10 years that they're learning
french at school they actually learn
very little the net result is or i
shouldn't say they don't they learn very
little but there's no evidence of what
they have learned now if they are put
into a situation
say they have to go to france it's very
possible that they did learn
not because of the tests but because of
the reading and the listening and the
exposure that they got to the language
and then when they're put in a situation
then we discovered that in fact learning
did take place
and so i feel the same way
so i i'm i'm never too concerned about
my my performance nor do i care that
much about grammar correction
uh
it's an element it helps i've got to
start noticing and in fact i do know i
do know for example in in arabic uh you
know the verbs are difficult i know
those are difficult concepts if i get it
wrong
uh and get corrected that doesn't mean i
get it right the next time
even if i get it right one time doesn't
mean i won't get it wrong the next time
so so i think it's very important to
in our strategy to stay focused on the
learning side of things do the kinds of
activities that are going to fill our
brain with
the language the sounds the structure
the words
familiarity with how things are you know
described expressed in the languages
increasing familiarity with the language
and not worry too much
about our performance if my goal when i
say in arabic were to be able to have a
short three-minute conversation in
arabic then i would focus entirely on
a limited range of subjects where i had
the vocabulary where i had the structure
and then i could sit there and three
minutes carry on this conversation but
then how much vocabulary am i
accumulating so my strategy is never to
try to master anything to nail down
anything but to expose myself and this
again it gets back to robert bjork about
you know his research on interleaving
that you can't you're better not to try
and block learn something you're better
to interleave different things so i'm
using three different sources of content
doing some easy material some more
difficult material and i know from
experience that as long as i stay active
in my listening and reading activities
and reviewing of words and phrases
that i am learning now
my performance
you know is is going to be up and down
and initially when i start speaking it's
not going to be very good but if i have
learned and acquired words and i have
good comprehension
then
in terms of the long-term
performance my ability in the long run
to be able to converse
and read and listen in the language then
as long as i'm pursuing a path of
learning
rather than worrying about individual
performance opportunities i will in the
end i will end up achieving my goal so
uh have a look at robert bjork's video
think a little bit about not getting too
concerned about your performance in any
given situation
focusing on
you know long-term learning
and that's not to say
just to end up that we don't need to
speak and eventually we need to speak a
lot
because having sucked all of that
learning into our minds
we need to
develop the ability to use it and to
activate it and that requires a lot of
speaking a lot of speaking without
worrying without worrying about the
rules of grammar without being afraid of
being corrected
and just a matter of getting it out
there and communicating and we will do
that well as long as we stay the course
of you know focusing on learning so
there you have it look forward to your
views bye for now
[Music]
you